hello folks welcome to
rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics
everybody else does
mathematics
what is mathematics
it's uh irrational science it's
the movement of concepts
you know they uh
what is it transfer energy
they wave the wave
they um
warp time
stretch the field
we don't do any of that here we do
physics here we only work with objects
we try to give physical interpretations
to
physical phenomena
and we also do extinction
what do we say we say that we are the
last generation of humans on earth
okay
and um
i don't know when it's gonna happen but
i'm all all i'm saying it's gonna be
very soon
okay whatever soon means to you could be
maybe 20 years to you 15 10
maybe even sooner
okay
and why is it going to collapse uh
the whole
humanity
because the
um
our economics our global economic system
will collapse that's
in a nutshell what it's about and so we
start by looking at
um
subject matter related to extinction
so let's start with this uh we have
anything related to extinction such as i
don't know uh
war
like world war three
uh genetics
technology related to you know our
extinction any of those are fair game
here okay
okay so here we have a little
note okay a little
uh
headline from one of the papers there's
a china taiwan tensions xi jinping says
reunification must be fulfilled
meaning uh
they're going to insist on getting that
little blue island there you know time
on
back to the uh mainland being part of
china they say it's a renegade province
and
people in the west uh
primarily the united states empire uh
says uh well you know you should do it
by peaceful means
well i don't know how you can do
something like that by peaceful means
you know the people on the island don't
want to be part of china and china says
you are part of us
according to history geography and so on
and so forth okay
so um
you better know how to spell taiwan i
think this is going to be bigger than
north korea the korea korean war it's
going to be bigger than the vietnam war
or afghanistan the day anyone fights
over taiwan i think it's going to be a
big war okay it could be world war iii
you know
so uh start learning how to say taiwan
from now on
you'll see i think on the news quite a
bit
next few years at least and according
the
article that i mentioned the other day
uh according to taiwan
taiwan uh politicians
china might be ready within four years
to
be able to fight for the island okay so
this is their assessment
okay um
someone says ironic hypocrisy of the
free
democratic world in the us australia and
india it is illegal for a state or
province to demand secession remember
taiwan is a province supposedly but
these countries host and promote
separatist leaders from other countries
one thing i learned by
being in politics for so long
is that you know
there's idealism a lot of idealism and i
was an idealist and people typically are
idealists when they're in their 20s
we're all hot heads
you know we we think we can conquer the
world we're all alexander the great
and
with time you learn what i learned at
least i don't know if you learned the
same lesson but i learned that there is
no justice out there okay there is no
ideal world
all we have is the world we have due to
the fact that
you know
interests clash and there's a difference
between what should happen in the world
what is
you could say rational logical the way
men should live we should all be equal
we should all have there shouldn't be
any people starving for example et
cetera et cetera et cetera you know you
get the idea uh that world doesn't exist
and never existed
never happened okay
the real world is you have a few rich
people uh maybe a
buffer there of middle class people
and then the masses of poor people
that's the way it's always been it's
always been a pyramid with a bottom half
being the big one you know the slaves
the serfs or whatever they were called
the proletarians or whatever they're
called in different ages okay
uh while someone at the top you know
they they have a great life well i don't
know about great life they have money
and power whether that gives them a
great life is a separate issue okay
okay uh someone says in contrast to the
swallow he says
you are completely wrong on the china
taiwan issue
taiwan is not part of china whoa
okay it's not part of china however
china claims taiwan is is theirs okay so
we got a little contradiction there or
some
there's something wrong there okay
taiwan isn't recognized by the u.n
nor the us as a separate country good
we're done right because of geopolitical
reasons
okay but they're not recognized as a
country right
they don't even have a uh team
in the olympics
i mean you know uh a real team like a
flag team
they're not allowed to to compete as you
know they're allowed to compete like uh
maybe
uh
scotland or wales would be in soccer you
know something like that
but not as a standalone country okay so
they're not recognized right if the
civil war remained a stalemate talking
about the u.s civil war 1860s the us of
today wouldn't exist and there would be
two
distinct different countries with two
different federal government okay
yeah uh
you know one thing uh people
i don't know if everybody understands
that
england
you know great britain
was not a friend of the united states
in all of the
i'd say
followed maybe i'm wrong by a couple
years all of the 19th century let alone
the
18th century after the united states got
you know did its revolution the united
states was an enemy of england england
was an enemy in the united states
and england uh you know went on the side
of the south
of the south of the south uh to try to
separate the two
pieces of land they you know divide to
conquer
and uh you know they they weren't
successful the south lost and even the
war of 1812 you know uh
great britain went in there to see if
they could reconquer
the territory and they'd do so well okay
so england was an enemy of the united
states throughout the 19th century hard
to believe right because you know
with the turn of the century world war
one and so on
uh
things changed completely around and
today they're great friends
and you know i guess all i can say on
that is what um
calvin coolidge once said he says united
states does not have permanent friends
united states has permanent interests
so do not be surprised if the united
states stabs a friendly country tomorrow
in the back okay
it always happened not only with the
united states all empires did that all
countries do that politicians do
whatever they need to do at whatever
time they need to do it and so that's
when you got to get rid of these
idealistic notions you know uh depends
on who comes to power he signs a
different agreement and it startles a
lot of people based on what interests
you get
the world is not driven by idealism it's
driven by interest
and another foul said the u.s would
level the fabrication plans before china
could get their hands on them
yeah uh it could happen in reverse right
i mean you know maybe russia
now that it's got this uh submarine i
talked about the other day uh that uh
launches
um
missiles
uh a thousand kilometers
from a submarine you know can launch a
nuclear missile
uh you know we don't know what's going
to happen in the future china might
expand its forces russia will expand its
forces
and so the question is you know will
this be like mad you know mutually
assured destruction
um
or will they sign treaties or you know
what will happen
and so yeah this notion that the united
states might destroy the factories of
china
it's got also a
downside anyways even if they were
successful and the downside is that
you destroy
the machine that that's feeding your own
country
because you know uh a lot of the
manufacturing today comes from china and
so if you kill the corporations assuming
that's the case you know you drop a
whole bunch of bombs and destroy all the
manufacturing
well uh it's like shooting yourself in
the foot today today it's a very
different world than it was a hundred
years ago
okay uh commerce is very important
international commerce and so you can't
just go in there and bomb places because
all you're doing is hurting your own
economy and the question is what if you
bomb a little too much
and then we can't recover
then it's like a pyrrhic victory you
know you
you shot yourself in the foot again
okay talking about war fella says
there will be a fourth world war but
with stones and sticks yeah einstein
said that right uh says i don't know
with what weapons world war three will
be fought but world war four will be
fought with sticks and stones the only
thing intelligent that einstein said in
his whole life
yeah
uh
yeah and
world war iii is easy it's nukes okay
i mean assuming that they they can limit
it to conventional weapons which i doubt
very much you know when politicians are
angry and they fear that they're gonna
be overthrown and even their populations
are going to kill them they're just
going to throw all the bombs so i doubt
that you can stop today at conventional
weapons
okay talking about weapons here we have
uh mr
[Music]
poutine and apparently the west is a
little uh worried about him says that
energy is being used as a weapon once
the warren's defense secretary okay the
need to counter unconventional threats
from foreign powers after downing street
race fears that a new russian gas
pipeline you know this pipeline that's
going from
primarily to germany okay from russia
race fears that a new russian gas
pipeline could present significant
security implications joe biden's
administration has accused moscow
outright of using natural gas is a
tool to pressure europe as prices soar
amid supply shortages
okay russia accounts for what 40
of europe's gas supply okay so uh yeah
this uh
second there was a first pipeline
there's a second pipeline uh they're a
little worried about that because it
gives russia whoever the next
um
rulers are if putin doesn't doesn't stay
till he's 100
you know it gives him a lot of leverage
over europe and europe is supposed the
friend of the united states both
militarily and economically
and that might change the balance of
power you know some of the countries
might
be pressured some of the politicians
really
different countries might be pressured
to go to the other side okay it's
happened in history before so don't
put it off like it's never gonna happen
yeah it might happen okay anything is
possible
okay uh here we have uh issue on covid
people say why did you get the covet
shot bill well i got it because i'm
going to travel i don't care about cove
but either way
i wasn't concerned about it for two
years i got my covet shot now because
they gave me hell
while traveling and so i don't want to
go through all the hassle of being under
quarantine any of that that's the only
reason i put it out there but here you
have a more important reason
mississippi news anchors off the air
after refusing corona vaccine gal
refused to be vaccinated
and they said okay you're out everybody
here has got to be vaccinated so they
put the pressure
on people to get vaccinated anyways
i think they're going to
pretty much require demand that you get
vaccinated if you're gonna travel like
on airplanes
and so it's just gonna they're just
gonna tighten the screws
and i don't know if you can avoid it all
you can do is maybe cheat on your uh you
know your vaccine card and they'll
probably make that also
you know to be directly from the doctor
to the country that's
uh
you know
receiving you so
i don't know if you can escape it
forever okay
and again uh one of the issues you got
to answer is you know did you ever get
vaccinated to go to school like
elementary school there are some shots
that are like mandatory so you may not
like
shots you know some religions do oppose
them right
but most people get vaccinated and then
uh and those are government mandated you
know it's like routine
and why would you care about getting
another vaccine like covet and again i'm
not vouching for for the uh vac this
covet vaccine i don't care about it i
don't even know if it's good or bad i i
really don't know because i'm ignorant
totally on that subject matter i
understand the theory you know
and uh bodies but
i don't know if it's real or not
i suspect it's real but i don't know and
it's a subject that i care
in the least
i don't care about it at all but see
this lady lost her job because she stood
by her
guns okay and here's another lady that
stood a little more by her guns he might
lose their life a colorado woman who
won't get vaccinated the night
transplant
doctor said they wouldn't give her a
what is it a kidney transplant
unless she got vaccinated
and
she's a religious uh christian born
again christian says my religion forbids
it and they say okay choose between your
religion and your operation
okay so yeah they're putting the
pressure on people out there okay so
it's up to you to decide
whether you want to fight city hall
or you know leave a peaceful life
at my age i don't have much to worry
about i'm almost 70 you know so i'm not
worried about um
you know if i have to die instead of
dying at the age of 80 i die at 75 or
whatever yeah it's that's life i've
lived my life pretty much other people
have different situations you're 20
years old well you might think in a
different way and if you work around
lots of people you also might think of
differently than the person who's at
home you know a home office or whatever
or unemployed
so you know there are different
situations not everybody can say the
same thing
about the vaccine right okay um
paul says prove that the conventional
mainstream medicine is wrong and that dr
weber's theory based on observation is
correct
cancer is caused by micro parasites
okay
i did not go to the he put a link i
didn't put a i didn't go to the link
because again it's a subject matter that
doesn't interest me in the least now
keep in mind in this channel we don't
care
about disease because we don't think
disease has anything at all to do with
extinction never cause the extinction of
a single species
on earth
uh and again you know people might say
well how about this animal here this
species that died because of a disease
well yeah if you've got uh the last
hundred individuals and they caught a
disease
maybe they all died because of that
disease that's not what led them to
extinction what and again i use that
analogy of the five neanderthals you
know these are the last five
neanderthals in a cave they're playing
uh poker you know and it turns out a big
boulder falls and kills all five of them
we find them we
discovered that they were the last five
neanderthals you know we do a
uh i don't know a carbon-14 test or
whatever
and we say oh they died so you know they
died because how did the neanderthals
become extinct they become they became
extinct because a boulder fell on their
heads
no no they became extinct
which what you got to answer there is
how did we end up with five neanderthals
that's the mechanism of extinction not
the fact that a boulder just by chance
fell in the last five same with disease
you know you can't say that the disease
killed the last hundred yeah that could
have been true that's not what led the
species to end up with a hundred
that's that's the real
uh mechanism of extinction that you
gotta discover
okay uh we had some people worried about
the women catching up with us there are
men who are worried about women
uh
you know uh we have this world in which
uh mass
what is it uh women are being masculine
and men are being are more femininized
and here we have these uh
three fellows one says women are
achieving gaining on men physically
going to catch up to men as an overall
species what is implied is that thinking
in that thinking is that men are no
longer achieving and gaining for them to
catch up
um
really what you see on the bottom it's
not that uh men are not progressing it's
that the distances between men and men
of the past
is uh
is is not as wide as uh the distance
between women
women are catching up to men in many of
the records weight lifting
and i'm talking about the the tough
sports will come okay weight lifting
wrestling boxing uh even soccer and
lesser
dangerous sports
uh women are getting into all these
sports
and the question is you know uh
they're catching up in other words
they're fighting and fighting better
they're running and running better
they're lifting and lifting better and
their progress has been much more much
faster in the last maybe 50 years than
the advancements among men
and so this is the issue the issue is
that they're catching up at least in
that sense will they ever catch up to be
exactly like men will women and men of
the same weight category for example
boxing or any other sport uh will be the
same
okay
and so this is the issue the issue is uh
will they catch up and people say well
no we've got testosterone and they've
got estrogen
so they can never catch up to us
uh okay let me give you a for instance
here well let me just cover these two
guys first top female olympic runners
cannot best high school boys and there
is no physical sport that women are
better than men at
and again you know it's uh
this is the state today
i mean if if you would have uh if you
would have been in the 19th century and
they said will women ever vote
men would have blasted women can't vote
they don't know how to vote they don't
know anything about politics
and today they're voting
in fact i think they're the majority of
voters
and uh so on i mean you can put that
almost anywhere i mean women in the old
days did not do as many sports as they
do today and they're getting into sports
a lot a lot of the reason for that is
because you know of money they want to
make money and so just like you have
beauty contests you have strength
contests uh miss uh muscle or whatever
okay so you get all these uh women who
are out there
getting into the business
and
they're becoming very good at what they
do
but let me get back to this issue of
estrogen okay you've got um
you take you get the coliseum right uh
roman style okay
and we put a man
toughest man you can find okay i don't
care
and we put a lion
in fact we'll put a lioness
to make it easy on him who do you think
would win
uh do you think uh you know a wild lion
is one one just taken out of the jungle
put in there right
do you think uh the man would win or do
you think the lioness would win
and he said well man i mean he's bigger
he
she's got estrogen he's got testosterone
yeah but i mean i'm sure the lioness can
run circles around that guy beat the
crap out of him and she's a female
and you can put you know maybe a dog in
there you can put maybe a wolf
a female dog a wolf
and i don't think a man can uh at least
an ordinary man against an ordinary
she-wolf
uh i think the she-wolf would win and
she's estrogen he's testosterone
so apparently there's something more
than just these uh estrogen and
testosterone
apparently there's something involved in
uh you know in training
we could say
how fast uh an animal is or whatever
you know uh
when um
when when god created man right
the bible says so so i'm just gonna go
by the bible says uh god created man but
he did it on the last day uh like mark
twain says he did it on the last day
when he was tired
but not only on the last day when he was
tired but after he had given after god
had given all his blessings to the other
animals okay
so uh when man came around he says uh
god uh
do you have a blessing for me
and god says oh
i gave all the blessings away i have
nothing for you i gave strength uh to
the uh you know to the
uh
uh elephants the bigness i gave also
those uh speed and strength to the lions
i gave the sharks you know their big
mouth and they could swim fast
i gave the eagles you know ability to
fly
and you know i have no no blessings to
give you you know more or less like uh
isaac when
jacob came around you know he he gave a
big blessing to jacob and when he so
esau came around says dad he got
anything from me
after he given all his
blessings to the
second born son
and his father said yeah i do have some
blessings for you you're going to be
your brother's slave
that was the blessing you gave him and
the same with man man goes to god and
says you have any blessings left for me
and said well you know i can't give you
speed or strength because we've given
i've given all that away
what i'm going to give you is smarts
and maybe dexterity that's all i've got
left in the box
okay
so man came around and eventually found
out that you know all these
blessings were pretty good in fact they
were maybe more powerful than you know
the speed the strength that other
animals had
and so man you know created cars and
says oh i can run faster than a deer
and he created a submarine and he says i
can go faster than a shark underwater
you know and uh i'm bigger you know i'm
not as big as an elephant but i can
build things bigger than him and i can
fly higher than an
egg know i mean he
all his arrogance went to his head
and so man got the idea that he could
also you know avoid extinction you know
the avoid death
and then he was maybe like the god that
created him you know immortal
and so yeah we we kind of
get this idea that we're not a an animal
out there but you have all these animals
in the wild and and they learn to
by their you know by their very nature
and their genes etc they learn to run
fast and protect themselves and they
know how to live in the wild
and we are not used to any of that and
so i they put a man against almost any
medium-sized a large animal out there
and he will lose
and so it's not about estrogen of
testosterone it's got to do a lot with
training speed a lot of stuff
and there are women which are very fast
there are women who are big they're
women that are strong
and a lot of these guys who say oh i can
beat a woman oh i can beat a woman
yeah i want to see you yeah like i said
the other day i want to put any of you
guys with ronda rousey out there in the
in the ring
and uh show them off the floor with you
okay my money's on her and after she
breaks a couple of your bones and puts a
leg twist a scissor on your neck and
leaves you there you know on the floor
you know asking you know crying uncle
she probably stands up and just smirks
at you and says oh by the way here's my
phone number if you
want to meet me again okay
yeah
people have in in their heads that
they're living in the days of genghis
khan that you know they went out there
and raped women and killed men and so on
we got a different world today you guys
got to get your feet back on the ground
because you know whether you like it or
not
we have a different world and in that
different world women have come up to
speed
and you'd be surprised what a lot of
women can do will they ever match men
well i don't think we know that
okay we would have to wait maybe 100
years to find out and i don't think i
think extinction will catch us before
then so i don't think women will match
us only because of that but given enough
time i don't know maybe they could i
don't know if it's a question of men are
always stronger than women
i don't know i can't tell you for sure
i'm sure there are women out there who
might be seven feet tall who are strong
and uh maybe they decide to lift weights
or earn karate i'm not sure how many men
will be able to
fight them and they'd be surprised that
maybe we have a
female world boxing champion or whatever
don't be surprised okay
okay let's continue here
someone talks about the definition of
life says what's the difference between
a dead guy and a living guy wouldn't it
be the processed verbs he's able to
carry out
yeah you discovered my theory by my i'm
sorry my definition and there's my
definition what is a living entity what
is something what is alive what does a
live mean well it's an object it's got
to be a natural object okay that moves
against the path of least resistance
primarily gravity okay if you can move
against gravity you're not a rock
you're not inert okay you're not a
molecule you're a little more than a
molecule you're like a cell or above
okay so yeah that's my definition you
got to do a verb
then we know that in a verb a self-made
verb
not that you know uh like some people
say well you know uh i throw a stone in
the air is the stone uh alive well no
the stone can't do it by itself that's
the issue see and so that's that's the
key issue life just a group of living
entities or things that are alive
okay
moving on here
fella says
by the administration minting a
trillion-dollar coin
do you think it factors into your
extinction hypothesis or is it just
another milestone in the history of
humanity
what is this fellow talking about well
um they've been talking about uh this
mentioning this trillion dollar coin
okay
uh platinum coin and what it is is you
know if the republicans do not approve
the budget
okay they want to raise the the debt
okay uh
the democrats want to
raise the debt ceiling and
republicans are saying no we you know
they're dragging their feet always
happens during politics uh politics uh
you know when it's the republicans to
raise the
debt limit same same thing with the
democrats etc it happens every four
years or every eight years whatever
and
what uh this is about is the fact that
um
you know the um president
executive power uh has the ability okay
or has the legal
um
mandate to go in there and create a uh
a uh
one trillion dollars
in um in coins because it it can it has
a um
control over the mint over the
um
the type of coin that can be printed for
example there's so much gold that can be
in circulation and the gov and what
controls that is the executive power
so if uh the
president of the united states decides
to go in there and mint coins uh
you know i can make a trillion dollars
if it wants to in coins
and with that flood the market or paid
the debt
and it doesn't matter what the
republicans do or say if they don't
approve the budget doesn't matter
because now the president puts the money
out of his own pocket so to speak he
gets it from god and just throws it
around so that's what they're referring
to well
whether it comes from the
executive power or from the legislature
it doesn't really matter you know the
point here is that if you put another
trillion dollars in circulation
uh in opposition to
congress right
well you're responsible for that okay
and that's what uh the republicans say
they say you want to vote uh higher debt
no problem we're not gonna vote we're
gonna cross our
our our arms and we're gonna let you
take all the blame for anything that you
put into that budget
and if you want us to vote and be on
your side on this well then you got to
take this and this and this and this
out of there that's the way it works so
yeah
biden can increase the money supply
maybe
some way by hook or crook but uh i don't
know i don't know if he wants to do it i
don't know if it's in his best interest
and for sure he won't do it
so
but uh the fact that um
the debt limit is increasing and is now
it was close to 99 percent of gdp
that should make you stop and worry you
know because right now debt is you know
in lots of countries but in you know big
countries the powerful countries
that is almost at the level of gdp what
we produce is what we owe
governments right
so yeah and that creates uh
a devaluation of the coin okay meaning
that if you get the same salary
nominal
salary then it's worth less
and that works to being worthless
okay
another thousand have you heard that mit
released some study that the world will
end in 30 years
yeah there's many theories out there
that the world will end in 30 years this
was a computer generated
prediction okay they put all all this
stuff in there and here here's the stuff
they put in there
let me get it give me a second here
this is what they put in there
okay and they uh put essentially food
and water energy climate
and
uh and more climate uh in blue there on
the right hand hand world population
growth rate of innovation the growth of
consumerism etc and you see all these
issues that they touched upon and they
put them in the computer and the
computer said well you know
uh we have a problem with with the way
the world is being run right now because
if we continue to do this you know the
population is going to outs
outstrip uh resources that's essentially
what it came down to aside from climate
change and some of the other problems
like pollution okay
and i just want to mention that this is
not my theory at all okay
theory is is you won't see it anywhere
you won't see it in the wikipedia you
won't see it anywhere the theory is
totally different has nothing to do with
resources has nothing to do with disease
and it has nothing to do with um
uh what other iss oh uh asteroid hitting
the earth or anything like that okay
it's got to do with one thing and one
thing only and it's what caused all mass
extinctions in the past okay this is the
theory the theory that all mass
extinctions happened in the same way and
they happened when
happened when
food was no more
okay that's how that's how animals in
the past died so there was no asteroid
hit 65 million years ago that killed the
dinosaurs there were no
methane seeping out of the ground in the
permian
there was no
supernova in the ordovician none of that
happened
what happened was the same thing over
and over the cookie cutter that mother
nature uses for mass extinctions and
that's the elimination of food
why does food get eliminated because
after billion
billions millions of years after
millions of years the plants lose their
genetic diversity and they die
ferns died conifers rose
conifers died
angiosperms arose and so on down the
line okay so what happened was a new
type of plant came on board why be was
it was it because it was uh
um
well it was a better plant it was a more
vibrant plant the one that came in but
the issue is that the one that left
had lost its genetic diversity in its
population pyramid overturned all the
species that lived for millions of years
finally ran out of gas
and the animals that forged relationship
with those plants died with them that's
what happened in mass extinction you
should be able to predict that kind of
occurrence if you stood at the starting
line of the cambrian and how do we know
that we know that in retrospect that you
know animals died periodically and
plants died periodically what were those
plants the plants that the animals ate
the herbivores ate those plants
um carnivores ate the herbivores they
all died at the same time that's a mass
extinction
and that's the same thing's going to
happen to man why is it because the
plants are going to disappear well yes
they're going to disappear because we
produce the plants artificially by hand
you know we do it deliberately
in order to feed uh feed 8 billion
people on the planet and the only reason
we do that is because of money
so all we need is a money collapse no
money is no more no one trusts in money
anymore no one receives money anymore
there is no trade
and at that point no corporation has any
reason to produce or distribute food to
the cities
that's the theory okay i just want to
mention what the theory is so that's not
confused with what these people say
which is oh resources population is
going to outstrip
resources
you know that's malthusian
theory where he thought that population
was advancing much faster than
resources and at some point they were
going to outstrip resources and you have
people like friedman come in and he said
milton friedman economist and he would
say well you know you for the right
price will produce it and distribute it
yeah but once price is no more then
friedman is dead okay so that's the
issue the issue is that money is what
will collapse it will collapse because
among other reasons uh you know we have
the debts limit uh being approaching gdp
we have the salaries of workers coming
down we have more services and fewer
things that produce real goods like
manufacturing and agriculture there are
several issues involved with why money
will disappear okay
okay let's move on here uh fellow says a
complete economic system like we have
will still operate if all services are
abstract yeah services are abstract and
we're just moving our hands around and
passing money around and the only real
goods coming out of manufacturing maybe
construction and agriculture those are
the things that produce real items
you know if you're god and you're
looking at the air from above
what you see is what exists
and what exists are the roads the houses
the boats the cars
the fields of corn that exists that we
can see we can touch
but um
uh
services you know i sing
i have insurance
uh i trade in bitcoin
that doesn't exist there's nothing there
all we're doing is passing money around
okay and then from that we buy things
that are real
and so the problem right now is what's
growing as services especially internet
services and what's being crushed out of
existence is agriculture has already
almost gone it's only about one percent
of gdp in almost any country or of labor
uh advanced nations
and in the case of manufacturing again
net advanced nations maybe have 15
or thereabouts so that's the problem but
it fell says abstract existing in
thought or as an idea but not having a
physical or concrete existence yeah
yeah so so there's no real existence in
services services is unemployment it's
just masked unemployment
and so here's my answer to that uh
service economic economy is 100 trade
that's what services is just trade
trade is equal to trust
okay you you can't trade without trust
you don't have trade in the ass in the
uh jungle out there you know lions don't
trade with uh hyenas
etc i can go through all whole bunch of
animals they don't trade there's no
trade in the jungle okay and humans
didn't trade when they were in the
jungle in the forest okay they didn't
trade
hunter gathering was a personal uh thing
okay and all the way to uh um
subsistence agriculture it was always
self-sustain sustaining okay
self-sufficiency so self-sufficiency is
not equal to service economy or trade
okay
there is no trading self-sufficient
economy
and anyways would you trade food for a
song
or for insurance or whatever
is that what you trade food when there
is no money around
and all you have is food
and the other guy comes over says uh
what do you want uh uh i want food so
what are you gonna give me
uh i can sing a song for you
[Laughter]
yeah sure
why don't you sing the song while we
watch you die
so no uh
trade is what's gonna die
okay anyways uh you gotta tell me the
following here we have spent two hundred
thousand years perhaps as hunter gathers
maybe ten thousand years as farmers
200 years 300 years as industry you know
since the industrial revolution we have
manufacturing
and now for the last maybe 50 years this
is no graph but maybe last 50 years or
so we've had services begin to dominate
the planet and services again like this
fella said is all abstract there's
nothing real there
all we're doing is exchanging money from
one person to another okay
and so yeah the question is will we have
services now for the next million years
that's the issue before you are we just
gonna have services for the next million
years
okay that's the question for you
and hopefully you don't say yes
[Laughter]
okay no there's no way we can have
services for a million years but some
people believe that that's the case
okay fella says uh are you absolutely
sure we're on the verge of extinction or
might this be a wishful thinking from a
disillusioned communist in the
post-utopian age
uh first of all i'm not disillusioned
communist i'm glad that i'm no longer a
communist okay and when i for
at least 20 years of my life i i was
into communism very deep into communism
uh that's that's what i believe that's
what i read about and i was very
idealistic
uh no i'm happy i left that behind it
was a good experience while it lasted
you learned a lot and one of the things
you learned is that it's ideal
you know uh what did lincoln say
all men are created equal you got that
from the constitution
uh no we're not created equal
you know some people are born blind
others without legs you know you got all
kinds of people out there so we're not
born equal we're not born also in the
same households some are born um
from the queen of england and some are
born you know from the pauper in the
slums so we're not born equal and not
even in uh in a legal sense i mean you
know o.j simpson you know he had money
enough to pay the dream team to get him
out of uh trouble
i'm sure if there was another black guy
out there he wouldn't have been as lucky
as oj you know and i'm sure a lot of
black guys would agree with me you know
so
no we're not born equal okay and so if
we're not born equal is there a
possibility we will ever be equal
in any way shape or form like in rights
in uh
income and money and uh goods that we
have in the life we lead
uh you won't see it out there in the in
the world of animals
nowhere have i seen communism not even
among ants or bees there's no communism
and so
this notion that
we're intelligent we can create an
egalitarian world
and no i don't think so not anymore i
used to think that
it was fun when i when i was younger to
think that you know when i looked back
and saying oh it was a great time yeah
but
it's a dream that doesn't exist anywhere
in the universe okay mother nature did
not intend for equality
even plants you know i grow plants one
plant grows big
and the one underneath you know it
doesn't get enough sun or maybe the
minerals from the from the ground or
maybe enough water who knows what and
grows
smaller you know there's no equality
among plants
okay
let's move on here
to the subject matter of today which is
distance
what the hell is distance
but before we get the distance let me
cover an issue that was left behind
i asked a person to answer some
questions related to one-way mirrors
and i didn't get an answer this time
either
and i lost hope
i'm getting an answer uh foul says if
laser pointer right used from a dim side
it shows up on the brighter side yeah we
know that we all know that i mean that's
he's just repeating stuff that's not
being asked
when that's when the lighting is correct
on both sides for the half silver glass
two-way mirror illusion to work yeah we
understand that too that's a description
you haven't explained anything these
effects have nothing to do with anything
else besides half silvering method
and again he didn't answer the question
so after five times i throw in the towel
i don't think the guy has an answer he's
just you know walking around the the
issues okay the question was very clear
i think i made it clear in the last two
times at least and if he doesn't answer
is because he doesn't have any clue
that's why it is
okay so uh let's let's get into that
let's find out what the what the problem
is okay and the problem starts there
where we have a man looking at a mirror
and the woman behind the glass she sees
him but she doesn't he doesn't see her
he sees his reflection in the mirror she
doesn't see him the question is
does light go both ways
why does light go to her eyes
but her light doesn't go to his eyes
this fella keeps insisting it's got to
do with something with a coating on the
mirror and something to do with the
lighting in the room
and the answer is no
quantum mechanics doesn't say that and
that's the question we've got the
question before us is what does quantum
mechanics say
quantum mechanics does not deal
with uh lighting in the room that's uh
classical mechanics okay quantum
mechanics deals with what happens
between the photon and the electron
which is a component
of an atom
so here we're talking about subatomic
interaction that's what quantum deals
with that's what quantum ma tries to
answer and we need to find out what does
quantum say about this situation
and it does and you won't find in
quantum mechanics anything about the
lighting in the room it's got to do with
something totally different the issue is
whether the electron absorbs a photon or
it doesn't that's what it's got to do
with so this for the fifth time did not
answer that question just
eludes the question because he doesn't
have an answer okay that's the only
issue
okay so let's look at this is the
quantum version here okay we have uh two
situations one is opaque and the other
one is transparent according to quantum
mechanics okay so i want to make that
clear this is quantum mechanic this is
how quantum mechanics answers that
question
says okay what is opaque well opaque
means that an electron gets abs or
energy whatever you want i'm sorry
photon or energy is absorbed by an
electron
if if the
photon has enough energy whatever that
is okay
fine says he doesn't know what energy is
okay
if it has enough energy it boosts the
electron to a higher energy level which
is a situation on the top so because the
photon is absorbed because the
the
energy is absorbed it doesn't continue
to your eye
okay that's what quantum says
and what is transparency well more or
less the same thing the uh the photon
does interact with the electron
but there's two possibilities one is
that uh it delivers the energy not
sufficient energy but enough energy for
it to vibrate and pass that energy
whatever energy is to another atom or
another molecule or whatever next to it
a neighbor and so it passes it off as
heat
the other option is that it
hits the photon the photon doesn't like
because it says well you're too weak you
don't have enough energy to boost me to
the higher energy level so it lets it go
by or spits it out one of the two
okay so what happens is there is an
interaction
of some kind but that interaction is not
sufficient
uh energy to boost it the electron to a
higher energy level okay so those are
the explanations of quantum mechanics
so what does quantum mechanics say about
what's happening uh in in the uh in this
situation okay in the one-way mirror
well quantum mechanics says that
light
actually travels in both directions okay
that's what quantum says but in one
direction it's absorbed
and the other it goes through
it's like you have holes and brick walls
holes in brick walls
so the photon hits a brick wall
and it gets absorbed or reflects or
whatever and when it goes through a hole
it just goes all the way through to the
other side that's what quantum says okay
that's the version of quantum that's the
one we have to address okay none of this
classical stuff saying oh the lighting
in the room oh the coating on the mirror
no none of that has anything to do with
the quantum version
okay and i think i made that plain
uh and if i just alluded to question
okay and so here we have it uh a
different version of the same thing
here's opacity this is what an opaque
substance would do
you have that green energy arrow okay
it
absorbs
the electron absorbs that energy and
jumps to a higher energy level then it
releases it back maybe through
reflection or heat
and uh it falls to a lower energy level
okay that's that's this is the quantum
version
okay
uh of
opacity this is opaque here's
transparency okay
in here in this case uh the
photon just goes through but it does
interact with that uh little electron
ball okay
uh i should have put it in there in such
a way that it touches the electron ball
to make that
planer okay but i didn't do that but
just think of it that green arrow hits
the electron ball
that red ball that's going around but it
doesn't have enough energy to hit it to
the higher energy level so the electron
just keeps rolling allegedly along the
same
orbital or
um
that yeah that orbital where it's going
around
uh or energy level
so these are this is how quantum
mechanics answers these questions okay
so this is opacity and transparency
according to quantum mechanics okay
let's put them side by side so that we
don't lose track okay
or up and down okay just so you can
compare i want you to understand the
quantum version this is the quantum
version okay case of transparency the
photon goes through so if you have glass
sio2
as part of the remember the coating on
the mirror on a one-way mirror
uh is very light
and what do you mean by that well what
we mean is that
when it hits like aluminum or silver or
whatever coating it's got on there
it's going to hit that brick wall and
it's going to be opaque like shown on
the bottom okay
if it
hits
the area where there's glass sio2 well
in that case it goes through according
to quantum mechanics but how does it go
through it
goes through through a little relay
mechanism where
the photon gets absorbed
by the electron well not absorb but it
touch the photon touches the electron
says no you're not you're weak we'll let
you go by so it goes by it has to
interact because otherwise you know how
does the electron know it's weak or not
so there's got to be a uh
gazillions of a second interaction
then the photon moves on to the next
atom then moves on to the next atom then
moves on to the next atom and comes out
the other side
that's what quantum mechanics says
that's the mechanism quantum mechanics
proposes okay so i want you to
understand the mechanism first okay
uh
so it's got nothing to do with the
lighting in the room it's got to do with
the fact that the photon will go in
completely through okay
and in the other case it gets absorbed
that's what it's got to do with
according to quantum okay
okay so here's a comparison between the
two okay
uh the one on the left would be the
fellow and uh one on the right would be
the gal who could see the fellow okay
and if you have an atom that is either
silver or whatever coating is made out
of it's going to be opaque and so it's
going to absorb the electron coming from
the left that's the
upper one on the left
and even if from the gal side you know
if
if there's a photon coming from the
right from her side it's going to be
absorbed by one of these
silver atoms and we're just putting atom
we're not even going to deal with
molecules we just want to look at the
process here okay it's absorbed by an
electron of one of those atoms
what happens under transparency well you
can see there it's a relay race okay
this is the mechanisms and the quantum
mechanics proposes you have a photon
coming from the left okay it's going to
be absorbed momentarily or it hits it
touches an electron
then continues to the next one because
it doesn't have enough energy to boost
it to a higher energy level and it goes
to the next one to the next one to the
next one it's kind of like a relay race
where they're passing the baton to each
one until it comes out the other side
this is transparency
so in one case the
photon is absorbed in the other one it's
allowed to go through that's the
mechanism quantum mechanics proposes
okay
and so what i want to do next i want to
compare
uh quantum against the rope model okay
so you can see
black and white you know yes or no on or
off one against the other
and here it is the rope model okay uh
all the atoms are interconnected by
ropes electromagnetic ropes you have the
laser high frequency
beam come from the
left here
and what happens is you have that high
frequency it boosts the pumping speed of
the atom which then transfers that same
pumping speed to the next atom and so on
down the line it's a relay race but it's
done all through this rope okay and
compare that against the ptolemaic
uh
mechanism that quantum mechanics
proposes where the photon is touching at
least the electron has to touch it at
least once and then continue on to the
next atom against the next atom and so
on down the line okay so it's up to you
to figure out which one
you would choose to be efficient which
one does mother nature use
okay does it use this
rope model or the use this particle
discrete particle model
that's the that's the issue you gotta
ponder okay
okay moving on here uh so let's go back
to distance
uh in order to talk about distance we
really got to
start at the beginning more or less i
can't say the beginning we never started
at the beginning even the universe had
no beginning accepting the religion of
general relativity in science no the
universe had no beginning meaning matter
was not created by god or by big bang
matter was always there okay
a matter cannot convert into space space
cannot convert into matter therefore the
at you know an atom cannot turn into
empty space into nothing spontaneously
for no reason whatsoever without cause
without mechanism and vice versa space
cannot suddenly pop into
and become an atom or whatever
so matter has always been there okay and
uh that's under the rope model okay has
no way of
matter has no way of disappearing or
being created okay like in the religion
of general relativity
okay but um
about 400 years ago yeah we're talking
about here um
the 17th century so-called 17th century
revolution
that's when science began began to
change a little bit
and what changed well uh we remember
people like galileo and um newton maybe
leibniz
huygens and some of the other luminaries
of those days
but they weren't really the first okay
they came like a generation at least uh
galileo came more or less a generation
later about maybe 20 years not even 20
maybe 30 that 10 years
later
but newton for sure came a lot
later than newton was born the year that
galileo died
so he was a generation even further
removed the people who came before that
were people like william gilbert and um
uh
roger uh not roger
gilbert
gilbert and what's the other guy i'm
here frank's speaking sorry
uh and here's uh william gilbert what
did he do for science
well not much but he played around with
magnets
and he wrote this book the magnetic
meaning
on the magnet he was writing a treatise
on the magnet
and he toyed around with a magnet and
what did he do for mankind well maybe
one thing only and i'm not even sure he
was the first one but uh at least in the
west he was and what he said is that the
earth is a magnet
and he playing around with magnets is
what
led him to this idea
and what i'm trying to say here is that
you know he was one of the first to
start doing experiments okay and that's
how experiments
kind of entered into science because
before that it was all thinking
pondering you know imagining visualizing
and they're trying to figure out how
this universe worked they couldn't
figure it out and these people started
saying well why don't we do some
experiments
and you know this was one of the first
guys to do experiments he did it with
magnets
a fellow in spain um francisco sanchez
and
he was
he was a philosopher as they called him
and he said the following and you can
see how the mind is changing at the
beginning of the uh 17th century 1600s
early 1600s so the search for causes
quickly descends into an infinite
regress and so cannot give certitude
you started questioning you know whether
aristotle was you know the greeks in
general were
were they doing the right thing okay and
he says syllogisms are circular you know
the syllogism started with the greeks
and do not add to knowledge
okay so he starts questioning
perfect knowledge if attainable is the
intuitive apprehension of each
individual thing
okay but science perfect knowledge of an
individual thing is beyond human
capabilities because of the nature of
objects and the nature of man
the limitations and variability of man's
senses restrict him to knowledge of
appearances never of real substances
and i don't know if he figured it out he
probably didn't because nobody has
to this day uh
[Music]
until
my book came along
and
i'm not bragging here i'm just stating
the fact okay and that's that nobody
figured out
that uh you don't do experiments to
figure out anything about light
magnetism
uh gravity
because you can't see or touch the
mediators mother nature uses so
uh he didn't really specify exactly what
meant by by what he meant by all this
okay he just says uh because of the
nature of objects what do you mean by
that
why would you do an experiment for
example
if why would you go to the lab if you
can't see or touch
the objects that mother nature uses
to do
all her magical phenomena such as
gravity and magnetism
you know you're going to go to the lab
what for
all you need is one experiment like i
say to talk about gravity and here it is
this is the only experiment you ever
need to do you let go of the pen
it falls to the floor to the center of
the earth or whatever
never falls to the ceiling we're done
now explain it
and you can't explain it until
you know you can surely you're not going
to explain it with math
math can only describe it
the only way you're going to explain it
the mechanism is by
visualizing by introducing by making
visible the invisible objects that
mother nature uses as mediators
so there's something here that's either
pushing from above or pulling from below
but something had better come in contact
with a pen
with the skin of the pen because
otherwise you're introducing spirits
black magic into your theory you're
saying nothing touched this at all
nothing came in contact with this
but it was always pulled to the floor
like if the pen knew it's got to fall
downwards and not upwards
so nothing came in contact with a pen
why because you can't see or touch it is
that why you say nothing came in contact
with the pen
okay so this is the issue yeah it had to
do with the nature of objects and so
what these people did was move in two
directions
experiments
and math
neither of which have anything to do
with science
science
is not descriptions mathematicalness or
otherwise
science is not running an experiment
you can run an experiment and not
understand absolutely anything
you can study all week and not pass the
test on friday so why did you study it
because you studied you you're a
scientist because you did an experiment
you're a scientist because you did some
math you're a scientist
now you're a scientist if you can
explain something in a rational manner
you can explain especially in the case
of physics a mechanism
then you're a scientist now you become a
scientist because now you're using your
your grey matter up there in the attic
okay so this is the issue
and so uh what happened was all these
people because of these original
pioneers of science they started taking
uh the
causes
that they had in the old days in fact i
think i have it here with francis bacon
give me a second here
um
you know he he he still was thinking of
causes okay in his novum organum okay
he said uh he he presented his method
his new method for science he said look
we got to forget about the greeks
and instead we got to look at this other
thing and he says he starts it with his
three main steps he says a description
of the facts
a tabulation or classification of those
facts into three categories instances of
the presence of the characteristic under
investigation instances of its absence
or instances of its presence in varying
degrees
and then the rejection of whatever
appears in the light of these tables
not to be connected with a phenomenon
under investigation and the
determination of what is connected with
it
so he was saying look we run an
experiment let's look at what happens
and based on what we observe right so we
have observation and experiment that's
uh that's what we're going to draw some
conclusions out of not out of this stuff
that aristotle says you know that
like he says a bigger stone will fall
faster than a lighter stone because it's
bigger and weighs more you know so
this fellow is now saying look what we
got to do some experiments is observe
them and uh from that we can reject some
theories and accept others that's
essentially his method okay
and so he presented this in 1620 which
was a little sooner than
galileo galileo is
you have to remember that first he had
his
two systems of the world where he almost
got in trouble with the church and then
he came up with that other system uh
which was he took up his old
practice of playing around with mass
and he wrote some balls and so on so he
came up with some ideas on how masses
behave
and newton's going to read that later on
and he's going to give some credit to uh
galileo and essentially develop from
there on his
descriptions because they're not really
theories they had no theories theory is
an explanation none of these people
explained anything all they could do was
describe and what they did said what
they figured out is that you know
masses like two different weights fall
at the same speed and they were shocked
by that realization in great measure
because they were taught something else
in school they were taught uh the air is
the italian version and they said well
no that's that's not true
and incidentally again it wasn't uh
galileo who threw the first
balls from the tower pizza
okay
so uh i've covered that in the past so
yeah this was an age when they were
starting to use
math experiments and what they were
leaving behind was this
uh
just explanations without any um
uh support from experiments or equations
okay so what they were working on
whether they knew it or not were
descriptions
okay
they were working on descriptions and
that's not what uh science is about
science is about explanations and we're
trying to figure out how this universe
works
okay
and by how i don't mean here's the
description no by how i mean the causes
and they tried to
up to this point they were still trying
to figure out the causes
causes died essentially in the roaring
20s when quantum took off and that's
when they figured out there's no way we
can ever explain this and so they stop
looking at causes okay and so we're like
feynman's gonna say many years later he
says you know physicists have given up
on that
okay so they don't look at causes
anymore that's considered philosophy
for the philosophers of science
philosophers of physics and they don't
deal with that stuff at all they just
deal with descriptions they go to the
uh
large hadron collider or maybe throw a
rocket into to the moon and they look at
what happens they measure and they give
you an equation and that's all that
mathematical physics is about
okay but that's not physics physics has
to do science especially has to do with
explanation you have to explain
how gravity where how mother nature does
that magic trick you have to explain how
a magnet attracts another that's science
and these people never figured it out
okay einstein you figure out board
didn't figure it out none other people
since then have figured it out okay so
uh where does this take us well what
happens was um all these people put the
set the stage you can say the
foundations of physics
and the foundations of physics are all
rotten to the core okay for example you
won't see in any book on planet earth
textbook of physics you won't see the
definition of the word object
and it turns out you know what a thing
is
and turns out you can't do a physical
interpretation
a mechanism
you know without objects i mean if
there's absolutely nothing in the
universe god hadn't made any material
any atoms any nothing what would you be
staring at you being there with god you
know drinking beer together right uh
what you would you be staring at if
there's nothing there
so the first thing you need in physics
is an object you can't do physics
without an object they never figured
that out
and so
that's where the problem started and why
because mathematicians have no use for
objects
they they simply represent objects with
point particles or
point numbers really and they start
moving the points around giving you the
idea that they're moving a physical
object when you say was that an object
well the that's the center of mass
so they're moving this concept known as
the center of mass around and they
forget about the elephant okay so that's
more or less the situation today so
here's a book that i have okay uh this
book
and it's a it's a book that um
uh
you know i've had for a long time it's
typically a type of book that you find
in high school in this case it's uh for
liberal arts in college it's people who
are not into physics per se
but they want to learn a little bit
about physics or it's maybe one of those
courses they take and they just want to
get an introduction to physics and so
it's a typical book for
people who start doing physics okay so
let's look at some of what the table of
contents are here and here you'll see
you know all these uh
titles there all these uh headlines
and if you look at that first group
there you'll find that it's all got to
do with
space with the solar system and so on
until you get to mechanics there number
uh page 74 okay
and what happens there is they start
talking for the first time about some of
the what
the mathematical physicists consider
physics okay
so um
what do they talk about well if you go
in there and look at that page you'll
find this mechanics okay and what do you
see there well
in that whole chapter these are the type
of things that you find
you don't find mechanism you don't find
explanations what you find is equations
and you say this is this is mechanics i
thought mechanics was you know like the
guy who works on a car he doesn't work
on equations okay
and so uh you go in there and you find
speed equal distance divided by time
great that's an equation angular speed
velocity acceleration and finally force
equals mass times acceleration
they're they're talking about motion
in all these cases that's where it
starts that's where the so-called
physics starts
okay and uh yeah when you look at uh
speed equal distance divided by time
well you can say also distance is equal
to time
times speed or speed times time okay so
you multiply those you get distance
okay but that's not distance
that's what is known as distance
traveled
and here you see uh what what i'm
referring to that's the that's distance
traveled because what they're doing is
rolling out the front end of a measuring
tape
okay is that distance is that the same
thing as separation between two objects
okay so this is where the problem starts
because what they're doing is they're
putting an equation you say well is that
distance speed time to time
no that's not distance that's distance
traveled because either you're laying
tiles or you're rolling out to the
measuring tape or you're counting
seconds
what you're talking about is frames of a
movie you're talking about something in
motion
is that what distance is motion
okay so this is where the problem starts
because these people have always looked
at distance as um
as something dynamic instead of
something that is uh
uh
static okay like a separation between
two things
okay
okay let me get rid of this
give me a second here
okay uh so
here we look at the word distance what
does it mean what is the definition of
the word distance and we go to the
wikipedia it says distance is numerical
measurement of how far
okay apart objects or points are
okay and how do you gonna find out how
far we're talking about an amount a
quantity
we're looking for a number okay
how far
in physics we don't care how far
in physics there is so much separation
that's physical
okay between the chair and the table
there's
there's a distance we don't care what
number distance that is in fact if you
go to the land of the klingons i'm sure
they're going to have different
measurements they won't have feed and
meters and so on they're probably going
to have a different type of measurement
and so there how far will be different
at least numerically right uh than the
how far over here
so how far is they're talking about an
amount
okay and that's not what distance is
distance is separation in physics in
math is how far okay in physics or
everyday uh usage distance may refer to
what
length
physical length
so in the religion of mathematical
physics
distance is the same thing as length and
length is the same as distance when you
look up the word length that's confirmed
is a measure of distance
okay so so length and distance in the
religion of math is the same thing
because what they're doing is extending
the tip of a measuring tape or counting
tiles you know you get a towel like one
meter and you put all these down say
well this from here to there's five
meters
okay so what did you do well you laid a
bunch of tiles and you counted how many
tiles
so we're talking about not distance
we're talking about distance traveled
how many how many steps how many tiles
you put from one end to the other or how
far how far the distance from the time
the runner started to the time the
runner ended what was the distance well
let's roll the measuring tape again the
front end of the measuring tape all the
way and measure and get a number get a
get a unit
that's what
that means in mathematics
in in science
uh physics okay something different we
can't use that for explanations that's
good for descriptions it's not good for
explanations in in science we have to
explain in order to explain we need
qualitative stuff
so we look at separation gap
chasm
okay
and we look at the dictionary.com it's
got maybe a little better one but again
they talk about amount of space between
two things points lines if they would
have left that part out and just say
space between two things then they would
have the definition of physics more or
less okay space between two things
that's what uh sp what distance is okay
and again the state of being far apart
okay those are the notions of physics
and so
they're irreconcilable uh between math
and physics okay
so we distinguish what mathematical
physics does and physics is a big word
i'd rather call it mathematics
uh with what we do in physics in physics
we don't use amounts we don't use units
we don't care about that because those
are descriptions we're not going to use
them at all what we're going to use in
physics is separation that's what's
going to be distance and we need that
separation to define the word location
which again is a static
qualitative concept okay it's not
location is not the position of
mathematics position again is motion
no such thing as position in mathematics
uh in the sense of what people think of
position like i'm at this position
that's not what it means in mathematics
in mathematics position is an ordered
pair that's what position is okay so
it's motion you got to go
10 feet this way and 10 uh and 10 feet
that way and now you arrive at the
position position is unrolling the
measuring tape also everything in
mathematics is dynamic there's no
static concept because mathematics has
no use for static concepts
okay uh so how do we define it in
science
here's a definition of physics of
distance the distance in physics okay
here we have it distance is what lies
between lengths
length is what a box has a table has a
thing has from one
side of the box to the other side of the
box for example
distance is the separation between two
boxes between two objects
so we summarize and say distance is what
lies between lengths
that's the
synthetic way of putting that okay
a little different than the notion of
unrolling measuring tapes or counting
seconds on a clock or whatever
all that has to do with math it has
nothing to do with physics
okay
here we have uh why that's important
okay why it's important to distinguish
between
the static distance of physics the
separation and the
so-called distance which is actually
distance traveled of mathematics okay
there's difference and here you can see
it in the equations that newton came up
with
they give him credit i'm not sure he
never wrote these equations uh those
equations were essentially uh written by
french
later on they took it out of his book
the notions of concepts and they turned
them into equations but that's you know
just academic that's historic history
whichever
when you believe it's it's your problem
the issue is the following we're going
to assign them to newton okay and we're
going to say that we have the
gravitational equation okay
and the distance there is different than
the distance in his
um
dynamic distance as i call it the force
equals mass times acceleration his
second law
and what do we see there well we see
that there's two different kinds of
distance the distance in the
gravitational equation is the distance
of physics
separation
that's what it is
it's a static concept that distance
you know so we're distance squared
and the other one is a dynamic distance
okay so these
two distances are not the same
qualitatively that's what i'm saying
okay
and what are the differences well
distance is uh static in the case of the
gravitational equation in other words
the
distance squared that's in the
denominator of the gravitational
equation
the other one is dynamic okay
in the first case uh the one on the left
uh distance is between two objects
the distance traveled of the second one
is
uh distance from the starting point of
the object to where you measure you know
so it's you're measuring a single object
you're saying this is the starting point
this is the ending point that's a
different distance than distance between
two objects okay separation between two
objects
each frame in the movie uh
depicts a static distance and the other
one has an itinerary
uh distance is towards the other object
and here's the distance away from its
starting point you can even if you put
an object that you're talking about an
increasing distance okay that's the
distance of uh newton's second law
distance is a measure of weight
in the case of the gravitational uh
equation in the other case
it's a measure of velocity
and then uh force uh increases when
distance decreases in the case of
uh
newton's gravitational law in the other
case it's force
increases when distance increases
so there are differences qualitative
differences in these two types of
distances
okay
and you say well what's the bottom line
why is this important okay
and here let me show you why it's
important you know one thing einstein
couldn't figure out was his principle of
equivalence he couldn't figure out the
cause
how mother nature does that magic trick
that this equation can be equal to that
equation and here you see it okay
we have one atom belonging to one
elephant so we're gonna have one
hydrogen atom only that's all we're
gonna look at here and this hydrogen
atom belongs to an elephant the elephant
could be falling to earth or maybe the
elephant is flying away from earth okay
and so what we're seeing is at a given
location
that elephant that that atom has a diff
a specific weight
if that atom changes position location
right if it's farther away or closer to
the earth it automatically has a
different weight
okay
so if you're standing close to the earth
you weigh different than if you're out
in outer space with respect to the earth
and so on down the line okay
so what's the issue here the issue is
that it doesn't matter if the uh the
elephant is flying out or coming towards
the earth that atom at a given location
okay
has the same value whether it's force
equals mass times acceleration or force
equals to you know the newtonian
gravitational equation there
okay that's the issue why because under
the rope model every atom there in other
words in this case this hydrogen atom is
connected to every atom on earth
and it has a certain number of ropes
converging upon it at that distance from
the earth
that's why the uh principle of
equivalence
that the cause the underlying cause that
uh for the principle of equivalence
and of course you know under fit under
math viz mathematical physics
mathematics you cannot explain it
because all they have is equations they
have no idea what's causing all this
they can't they they have not figured
out that all these atoms could be
interconnected
okay that's that's where the problem is
that's where the problem starts they
simply think that what they're staring
at is just the hydrogen atom and the
elephant they say well why if the
uh why is in some cases under these
circumstances force equals mass times
acceleration the same as the other one
why are they equal and what they do is
measurement they say well they're very
very equal yeah no kidding
because the number of ropes converging
upon that atom at that distance is the
same
irrespective of whether that atom
belongs to a feather or an elephant
okay
okay so there uh
that's in a nutshell why
uh distance is important quite from
qualitative point of view you need to
determine whether you're talking about
distance traveled or distance separation
and in physics we deal with distance
meaning separation we don't deal with
distance traveled in other words we
don't care
about units and we don't care about
amounts
because those are just descriptions and
those cloud if anything are
understanding rather than enlighten us
what we need to figure out what
invisible objects
mother nature uses to produce these
effects
that's that's what physics is about
okay let's look at the questions and
comments that people made since last
time okay fella says
um
maybe you could see straight through
this space like the photons do because
due to the four-dimensional magic the
photons fly straight
and only human bumpkins can see
confusing movies in the night sky
i don't know how much
this guy injected in him he should stay
away from so many
coveted injections he should only take
one
with his head can you explain why the
light or unbendable roast bend around
example stars my god i covered that in
the past i'll i'll do that again right
now but because it's relatively quick
uh but
yeah he doesn't have even the
imagination to figure this out okay and
produce deflection of starlight passing
near the sun
well uh another fellow answered more or
less uh he did a pretty good job of
synthesizing the answer so i'm going to
use his answer first and then i'll show
mine okay but here it is uh first i want
to show you this the fact that what
we're talking about and that's you have
light from a distant star and it goes
around our sun according to the religion
of
general relativity
and that's how it reaches our eye
because
this uh light curves around the sun
and the problem here is that uh that i
mentioned the other day is if it curves
okay then we know that we have
acceleration
that means that light has to travel
faster around the sun in order to
produce this effect
and so the issue here is uh does light
travel faster than light when it goes
around the sun
and so since the mathematicians could
not answer this question they had to
invent the fourth dimension
that's what they did and so they said
well
in our world it looks like a curve but
in the fourth dimension it's a straight
line
and so what they did essentially from a
physical point of view is put it beyond
your reach you cannot understand this in
our 3d world they say well it's in the
fourth dimension well how do i get to
the fourth dimension to prove that this
is correct and they say well you can we
have no way because we're 3d beings
caught in this 3d world and we can't see
that fourth dimension like a
two-dimensional being would not be able
to see our three dimensions
so this is how they got around they they
simply put it beyond your comprehension
behind beyond your
your ability to uh even understand it
let alone verify it right in any way so
by putting by inventing this fourth
dimension they they got away from the
problem they sidestepped the issue okay
and so one fellow answers and he says
the following and i think he did a
pretty good summary so i'm gonna put
this up here
these poor mathematicians cheat with
their idea of curvature there is no bump
into the outside as is often illustrated
called extrinsic curvature
uh general relativity
magicians yeah mathematicians talk of
intrinsic curvature which is
quantification or prediction of a
measurement they recognize that the
weird thing that happens on a sphere
called uh hellonomy
where you walk a quarter of a
circumference turn right walk again turn
right walk and then get back to where
you started with only two right turns
but then they ignore the altitude of the
earth's surface the curved path that was
actually taken on the 3d earth and call
it a 2d surface with the quarter
circumferences being straight geodesics
again geodesics in one it's straight in
the fourth dimension it's curved in our
world right and they and again it's got
to do with motion and not with a curved
line they're talking about itineraries
when they talk about geodesics
and they quantify this property to the
whole to the earth in a metric how
things are measured remember geodesic
they say is a straight line you say well
it's not a straight line because it's
curved around the earth but they say
well it's the shortest path on a curved
surface and because they're talking
about path they're saying it's a
straight line because you're always
moving straight ahead so this is a
game of words that they use where they
introduce their mathematic mathematical
concepts in lieu of the physical notion
of what you're doing you know if you're
walking a curve around the earth you're
walking in a curve i don't care if
you're walking straight ahead as they
say so this is a game of words that's
all it is that
mathematical physics has done here this
law continues he says they then
extrapolate this to the empty space out
there in the cosmos and say mass
distorts the ordinary metric into a
curved one right
light is not deflected around stars as
much as it transitions from one metric
to another but all the while taking a
geodesic path again geodesic is that
curved itinerary okay which they call
straight
that is to say light does not accelerate
to change direction but only because the
gr magicians are using curved rulers the
metric they think curve is a number or a
relationship between locations instead
of a property of a ball or banana
okay actually due to the mathematics of
geodesics light does accelerate with
reference to an external hyperspace in
which the universe would be embedded but
gr considers this the same question as
what does space bend into they claim
it's a uns
scientific as unscientific as asking
what came before the big bang or what is
space expanding into right all they've
done with all this stuff keep in mind is
elude the question they they've um they
essentially
sidestep the question
okay so this is this is where
mathematical physics is at and the
reason they're there is that um they
have no way of explaining mathematics
has no way of explaining what's
happening out there in the universe
something as simple as why the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system they
have no physical interpretation for it
because what what are they going to say
that space time is curved what do you
mean time is curved
what kind of physical interpretation is
curve time
gravity terms time or mass curves time
what idiocy is that that's nonsense
that's godly goo
talk that's all it is you can't say that
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system because time is warped and comes
against the skin of the earth
that's idiocy okay and that's the that's
the theory that einstein proposed that
is his explanation we don't care about
the math it's irrelevant we want to know
why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system okay so
you got to put it in the right context
okay uh and so here's my
answer this fellow uh this is why
uh
the the light doesn't have to curve
around the sun with ropes what we have
is the ropes are straight in other words
taught
the word straight is really incorrect
they're taught they're pulled taut
from the star to the corona of the sun
which and the atoms from the corona of
the sun
the ropes that are connecting it to your
eye are also taught or to the camera or
whatever you're using and so
it's all done with straight lines
there is no curvature okay
but obviously you know some people have
trouble understanding that and they
think light is curving and when you say
well
then it's accelerating no no because it
does it through the fourth dimension
it's a geodesic oh okay
and they go along and they just believe
it on the basis of authority
okay so this is where we're at today
okay uh here we have another
question another comment paul says
is it accurate to say
pull is due to universal motion
inverse of mach's principle mac's
principle is that you know all
everything in the universe is pulling on
you somehow
okay that's more or less that when you
turn around and you feel some resistance
there
aside from the air right
it's really the stars in the universe
that are pulling on you somehow okay
and uh newton had that with this
newton's bucket if you look it up you'll
find out what i'm talking about
anyways he says example proposing a
spring under tension between two objects
okay you would expect it to pull the
objects together but this is starting
motion magic
you know you don't have you can't talk
about the beginning of motion anymore
that you can talk about the origin of ma
of matter of an atom where did an atom
come from well certainly not from empty
space okay
and that's what mathematics essentially
says
so to scientifically explain a spring
doing a thing in other words in the
theory with a rope can the spontaneous
behavior of the spring be attributed to
connected atoms in distant galaxies that
were moving and getting to the spring to
do its previously magical pulling what
causes a stretched or compressed spring
to deform back to its equilibrium well
the problem with uh what this foul is
raising is this has nothing to do with
gravity which is what he's talking about
when he's talking about mach's principle
about being pulled by every atom in the
universe because under the rope model
mock's principle has an answer finally
you know and that is that yeah you're
connected to every atom in the universe
physically connected through these
electromagnetic ropes that we can't see
or touch okay so don't go out there try
to do an experiment don't strain your
eyes you won't see or touch it okay
can't see it or touch it and so this is
an issue of molecules this has to do
more with electromagnetism than it does
with gravity
so
the question's out of context in in the
context of the rope model this has
nothing really to do very little to do
with gravity which is max principle
remember
and you can look this up gravitational
force is much much weaker locally than
electromagnetism and this is an
electromagnetic phenomenon at the
molecular level
so
you're asking a question of gravity for
a an issue that has to do with molecules
okay uh
another follow he says
uh maxwell described light yeah first of
all he described he didn't explain
anything okay he had no idea maxwell had
no idea whatsoever but he said he
described light mathematically right as
a propagating wave whatever wave is
what's a wave well that's that bunch of
vectors that you see down there at the
bottom left
so wave is nothing
and of electric magnetic fields what's a
field well that's a bunch of numbers
that are vibrating
so all we have so far is nothing
we have uh description
in terms of math vectors
magnitude and direction and field but
vibrating numbers bunch of numbers
that's all we have
okay so maxwell had no idea okay
uh he was just as ignorant as the last
mathematical physics of today
that is electromagnetic
dispersing electromagnetic radiation
whatever radiation is there's no
physical object called radiation as the
light spectrum in physics a field oh
what is a field is a physical quantity
so he confirms that a field is just a
bunch of numbers just a quantity
okay
so if it's a quantity is it a physical
object obviously not okay
represented by a number
so so far we have nothing yeah we have a
counting
that's all we have or another tensor
that has a value for each point in space
and time yeah that's what the definition
of field is a value for each
uh point in space
so you have all these values which is
what you see there on the bottom right
that's a field a bunch of values
in space around an object that's it they
get stronger that's why i put the nine
in the center because it's stronger
towards the center of the object and
weaker as you go out so if you look at
gravity the closer you are to the center
of an object the stronger it is the
farther away you are the weaker it is
what is a field it's the notion of all
these values in space and they get
weaker the farther away you get from
ground zero that's all it is okay so
it's so what is a field bunch of numbers
what is a wave bunch of numbers because
it's uh two fields and the uh at least
the
electromagnetic wave has two fields one
the electric field the other one the
magnetic field what's a field bunch of
vectors or a bunch of numbers a bunch of
nothings
just mathematical
concepts abstractions there's nothing
physical there you don't have a it
doesn't belong to physics physics you
need a physical object okay
and this has led physicists to consider
electromagnetic fields to be physical
entity yeah it's not a physical entity
they consider that because they never
defined the word entity they never
defined the word object they never
defined the word thing
why because mathematics has no use for
things
it doesn't deal with things with
qualitative stuff it just deals with
numbers that describe things especially
motions of things how things behave how
things move
making the field concept a supporting
paradigm of the edifice of modern
physics
not modern physics modern mathematics
okay that's that's the correct term
mathematically they all the explanations
are magical
so yeah
that was quite funny
[Laughter]
a guy just has a bunch of concepts
that's all he can propose
and
uh saint paul he continues says nikola
tesla
uh i like i like his heroes listen to
the heroes he's got did an interview
that's on the internet called everything
is the light yeah except that he
couldn't tell you what light is so if
everything's light just tell us what
light is and we're done
very simple walter russell another bean
brain out there
thought along the same lines
yeah i guess they were all in the same
asylum okay
in the secrets of light secrets of light
this is made very clear
okay
victor schauberger
the water wizard
okay we have we have wizards now okay
was keen almost lights uh about lights
relationship to water in his sacred
living geometry yeah i like the fact
they use all these fancy words the the
water wizard the sacred geometry
i mean i don't even know why these
people enter physics or
even find an interest in physics they
should just go to church and you know
pray
einstein said everything is energy yeah
but uh he didn't know what energy was
and he didn't know what light was and
this guy says these men were correct
well yeah i mean
correct is an opinion you know here's a
here's uh einstein's energy okay it's a
that spirit there
and you just want to make sure that uh
spirit goes upwards and not downwards
okay you may not want to be down south
okay
this this is all this is all they have
today just spirits called energy
and uh
just in case
uh give me a second
here let me get rid of this
just in case we have mr fineman okay he
comes in and he tells us that what
energy is and what does he say he says
[Music]
it is important to realize that in
physics today we have no knowledge what
energy is so we have energy is light
great light is energy we don't know what
energy is
great i guess we made lots of progress
in mathematical physics okay and just in
case just to rub it in just to
throw the icing on the cake uh
good old uh fine one says i think we i
can safely say that nobody understands
quantum mechanics
nobody knows how you can be like that
the more you see how strangely nature
behaves the harder it is to make a model
that explains explains remember that's
what he uses right how even the simplest
phenomena actually work so theoretical
physics has given up on that
what do you think now this is a nobel
prize winner who tells you this in your
face
and when you tell that to some people
out there they say well no he he meant
something else they they do understand
because otherwise we wouldn't have
computers
if quantum were wrong you know they give
you that kind of nonsense kind of answer
ignorant people that's all they are
people who bow down to authority that's
all they are
okay a fellow
says uh
brookhaven national labs uh produced
evidence
yeah they produce evidence that means
they're gonna try to convince you of
something right when they when the uh
prosecutor presents evidence what is it
for to persuade the jury okay that's
what evidence is used so yeah they
produce evidence okay i guess they have
to make sure that their tax dollars
produce some results right this is a
national this is a government
institution
collisions of light produce matter and
anti-matter
what does anti-matter look like
how is it different uh
visually than matter
i mean you know if you have an atom a
hydrogen atom
uh what's different from a matter
hydrogen atom and an antimatter hydrogen
atom
one is blue and the other one's red i
mean i don't know uh got to clarify that
light is a medium we can manipulate into
matter
like silly putty you know
soon we will have replicators like
like on star trek
so now you can see where this guy gets
his
education he watches star trek he said
oh the replicator okay electrons behave
as if they live in a what fractional
number of dimensions so you have length
width and height and you have a fraction
of length you have a
fraction of width
holographic fractal light oh my god
we have fractal fractions of light now
we have right here the route to free
unlimited energy what is energy oh we
don't know nobody can define energy okay
we don't know well if you define it it's
even worse because that means it's not a
physical object we point to objects and
define concepts if you can define energy
it's not an object and certainly the
only way you can point to energy is if
you
give it some shape okay
uh maybe maybe it looks i think i've got
it here give me a second see if i can
find it
uh
no i don't i thought i did
okay anyways the route to free unlimited
energy isn't in what is waving
okay
it's in what is causing the waving of
light
okay what causes the wave of light
uh he didn't finish that it would have
been nice if he gave us an answer to
that question instead of just putting it
out there you know
he said nothing so far
okay uh paul says
this is an off topic but you
you read comments so just wanted to ask
what could be going on with la palma
volcano
okay volcano supposedly it's gravity
waves which of course is pure bs could
it be haarp please check and he gives a
uh
a
location there and i lift it up it looks
like that
volcano there and they say well that's
um
gravity waves that you're staring at
there
and the problem is that you know people
just label things and they don't even
understand what they're looking at okay
so when when the government or whoever
says oh we found gravity waves oh we
found a black hole
people don't ask them the right
questions okay
and so i can ask this guy is to go if if
this is what he thinks is out there i
don't think he does because he's
criticizing it but
he should go out there and say what do
you mean gravity waves all i see is a
bunch of smoke or
you know
some kind of uh
air moving
dirty air moving
through the skies what's this got to do
with gravity
you know gravity waves or something else
has to do with um supposedly according
to quantum mechanics sorry general
relativity has to do with mass
bending you know the
space time
and the gravity wave supposedly moves
along the canvas
of space time
and when you ask them well what does
this canvas look like they say well
you're asking an unscientific question
that's the answer to that so no gravity
waves there's no such monster as gravity
waves what we need to identify is the
mediator of gravity until you point to a
physical object something that has shape
you don't have an object and so you
cannot talk about gravity waves because
gravity is a concept wave is a concept
and two concepts do not an object
make
okay
file says
tides the real explanation and he puts a
link there okay so i go to the link see
if i whether i find out there what i
find there
and i find this uh essentially this is
what they had uh in a little uh
video okay i just took the
pictures from each one of the
frames there and this is all the guy had
i just want to point to you to the
ones i marked in red there that i
squared in red
it says to understand the mechanism yeah
i want to understand the mechanism okay
let's see and he says tidal forces are
explained by trigonometry
explained by trigonometry i thought
trigonometry was math
math can only ex describe it cannot
explain anything
so this fellow doesn't understand the
difference between an explanation and a
description
okay so we continue okay let's see what
maybe there is an explanation somewhere
he says gravity force is equal to the
force
great
okay and then what does he conclude he
says the title force pushes the water
well i don't know how force can push
anything force is a concept what you
have to do is identify an object if
you're going to give me an mechanism
like you said at the beginning if if you
want me to understand the mechanism you
have to have physical objects not
equations
what you did is describe and turn that
into a an explanation that's what
happened here okay so
yeah this is the problem that people
don't understand the difference between
an explanation and a description and
they think they're synonyms they're not
okay
they're not physic uh description is one
thing you can describe a chair you know
backrest to armrest uh
a seat four legs
i can put it mathematically say four
plus one plus one plus one there you
have an equation
is that science
i measured i measured four you know
counted
i can even measure until give you you
know mass and
how much material there is all that so
that's a description
i need an explanation of something
that's where you have to break your
brain and what we need to explain is the
invisible stuff we've already explained
the visible stuff and they considered
that physics
but then when they couldn't explain the
invisible intangible stuff
that's when they said well that's
philosophy
gravity you know uh gravity is this this
is uh 9.8 meters per second square but
that's not gravity that's the
acceleration of gravity of value
yeah and you say well what caused that
oh that's on the other side of campus
philosophy
we don't deal with that here
but then they try to give you an
explanation and they say well what is
gravity well gravity is the bending of
space time
so what is space time well you're asking
an unscientific question you're asking a
question that belongs to the other side
of camp yeah but sees all they do is
just escape
the questions and like mr feinman says
they've given up on that they've given
up on explanations they realize they
cannot explain the causes the physical
causes the mechanisms the only way
you're going to figure out a mechanism
is
like gravity or magnetism is by
identifying the physical objects that
are working in that invisible intangible
world
so no experiment is going to help you no
math is going to help you okay the only
way to figure it out is by imagining
what mother nature could be using trying
to visualize it make the invisible her
invisible
uh
mediators make them visible then you're
going to understand
what how this universe works
otherwise you won't understand it
okay uh faucets
what is the difference
i like this guy he talks about observing
another observer
what is the difference between observing
experiments and those empirical demos of
alignment quantity temperature stiffness
and frequency that i showed in the last
couple weeks
both involved observations
from observing that's where you form
your assumptions hypothesis to interpret
these phenomena including experiments
okay so this is what he's saying
well let's answer him okay here are the
answers
okay
uh why gawking is not a part of science
we don't call it observing we call it
gawking every time someone gawks we
uh point it out to him and here we have
good old stephen gawking and he's gonna
tell us something okay he's gonna tell
us that he's never seen a black hole
okay he never observed one
and so the first one is in mathematics
observation means proof
that's the context that's the first
context you need to realize otherwise
you have no experience whatsoever in
so-called physics in the scientific
world if you haven't realized that in
the religion of mathematics every time
they use the word observation what they
mean is i proved it
like i saw it with my own eyes i touched
it with my own hands that's what they
mean by observation that's why the word
observation was introduced into
mathematics
because they say i observed i went to
the lab i observed
so did you observe the mediator of light
did you observe the mediator of gravity
did you observe the mediator that moves
inside what is known as a magnetic field
and the answer is no you can't because
you cannot observe or touch
those mediators they're forbidden to
humans
okay or any other animal anything living
okay so uh did uh guru stephen gawking
ever observe a black hole absolutely not
does that mean he cannot theorize about
a black hole because he's never observed
one he just makes a an assumption he
says let us assume there is a black hole
okay and then he can move on to tell his
theory he doesn't have to observe a
black hole okay
and can you observe the mediators of
light gravity and magnetism can a blind
man be a scientist i mean you know
he doesn't see the moon so he says well
the moon is not an object it doesn't
exist i don't see it so it's not there
great so he cannot be a scientist he
cannot make an assumption say let us
assume there's such an object such as
the moon which i've been told about
right
and in science we do not describe and
that's what all these people do science
we do not describe what we do is explain
and in order to explain we make
assumptions it's not called observation
you did not have to observe anything all
you needed to do was make an assumption
and people don't understand that
difference and that's why this fellow
asks this dumb question
right
okay but let's go further on this let's
make sure we rub it in all the way okay
what is a hypothesis
okay here it is hypothesis an assumption
did you need to observe
and the answer is no and you'll see in a
minute why we don't we do not have to
observe anything we can be blind
whatever
uh what is the hypothesis we need the
objects the definitions in the statement
of the facts does that mean you observed
the object
did you have to observe the object to
make an assumption
and he answers no we don't use our eyes
we don't use our hands in science we use
our minds we use our brains okay
and so let's start with uh
something that is beyond your
observation so you don't introduce the
word observation anymore okay
uh again a hypothesis sets the stage for
an explanation which is founded upon it
known as a theory okay just in case
okay so uh let's do something let's do a
little uh thought experiment
not a real experiment it's a thought
experiment okay and what we're going to
make sure is that you cannot use your
eyes
okay we don't want you using your eyes
and you can't use your hands let me tell
you why because this
observation
this
this phenomenon happen in the land of
the klingons on the other side of the
universe
okay so you can't see it you can't touch
it because you're stuck here on earth
at least for now
and
something happened over there in the
lang of the killing guns and i'm gonna
theorize about it
i haven't been there
okay i haven't touched it i haven't seen
it
but we're gonna theorize about it okay
so let's find out we can theorize it
we make an assumption we say uh let's
assume there's a hole in the wall
okay
and so uh now we have different
theorists and they're gonna try to
theorize what caused that hole in the
wall
okay so one fell says oh i know
it was a unicorn that made that hole in
the wall the unicorn just kept banging
it with his horn and he just made that
hole
okay and someone in the audience says
well i don't believe in unicorns
well i don't care if you believe in
unicorns i made an assumption so let us
assume
unicorns exist
and once we concede the assumption i can
explain my theory of how that hole was
made i'm saying the the whole was made
by a unicorn
and one guy says you know i don't
believe in unicorn well i don't believe
in you
okay
and then another fellow goes in there
and he says well i don't think it was
made by a unicorn i think it was made by
god
god stuck his finger into the wall and
just drilled in and that's why it's so
perfect because only god could have made
such a perfect circle
atheist jumps up from the crowd and says
well i don't believe in god
oh you don't believe in god yeah i don't
believe in god
oh and uh so uh
what uh what are we supposed to do
because this guy made an assumption he
said let us assume god exists and he
made that hole with his finger and the
other guy said well i don't believe in
god well i'm just trying to explain a
theory to you you know whether you
accept my explanation for how the whole
was made that's your problem but that's
my theory that's what that's what i
presented that's the mechanism i'm
presenting to make the whole
okay and then finally we get a
relativist to come up there and tell us
all exactly how that hole was made
okay and so he goes up there and he says
no
it wasn't made by unicorn it wasn't made
by god
those ridiculous assumptions no it was
made by time
time bent in there through gravity and
that made that hole in there
that's that's how that hole was made
well uh what are we gonna say that we
don't believe in time is that what we're
gonna say
no we're gonna say that the other two
guys are a little more rational because
one presented a horse with a horn
the other guy presented a man with a
finger
and this guy's presenting a concept that
he's turning into an object
did he observe time
did the other guy observe a unicorn the
other guy observed god
no we don't not have to observe we can
make an assumption without having
observed anything
okay
and so that's the bottom line we do not
need to observe we do not need to use
our eyes we use our mind a blind man can
be
a scientist he you know he's blind
someone comes to him and says let us
assume we have this problem out there in
the land of the klingons
how would you
think that came about
i just want to know the mechanism what
comes through your mind that could have
created this and we come to you sir guru
blind man because we know you're very
intelligent very experienced and we're
not smart as you are and so the guy says
okay you blind as he is he says okay
this is i think how it happened or could
have happened according to my experience
did he observe through his blind eyes
did the other guy observe maybe he just
created a situation you know he says uh
there's a hole on the moon how it could
have had happened
we've seen it with our telescope you
know or maybe he didn't see it he just
said what if there is a hole on the moon
and he said well it could have been
caused by an asteroid
and so he gives it an answer
did anybody see the hole maybe it's on
the other side of the moon for all we
know so no we make an assumption we
don't have to observe
certainly you're not going to be able to
observe
observe you know like with your eyes
you're not going to be able to observe a
magnetic field whatever causes the
magnetic field you're not going to
observe the mech the mediator of light
you're not going to be able to observe
the mediator of gravity
okay you're not going to be able to
observe you're not going to be able to
touch them see them or anything so
all you can do is make an assumption
about the invisible mediators mother
nature uses to do those magic tricks
okay so we don't need to observe in
science observation nevertheless is used
by the mathematicians to say proof
that's what the word observation means
in mathematical physics mathematics it
means proof means i proved it that's
what observation means are you going to
doubt me i got a nobel prize you're
going to say i didn't observe that in
the lab
that's what the mathematicians say
with that i'll see you next time
and uh we'll continue this line of
reasoning
we'll see that